it is very rare to get temperatures in
the one
teens for this time of the year but it's
going to happen 106
outside right now henderson 104 north
las vegas coming 107 not much wind
outside right now
we begin in centennial hills up there in
providence at 106 for you 102 summerlin
104 for aleante the east side coming in
at 108 for sunrise mountain and
108 also for green valley and whitney
ranch 108 rhodes ranch
and seven hills 104 degrees downtown and
north las vegas currently at 107 106 for
prep
114 out there in inyo county for death
valley and 113 currently
for laughlin the doppler network not
picking up anything
dry west dry east even in arizona and
utah the reason for that again that high
pressure
in charge in place that's keeping with
us dry
it's keeping us hot it's deflecting any
precip headed our way
and it keeps us very warm for this time
of the year that high is going to be in
place and that's why temperatures will
get to record-breaking territory in the
meantime though
there is a reprieve i think you'll like
this by the time we get to tuesday and
monday we'll see those winds pick up a
little bit more windy on tuesday
ushering that change
cool air to follow and then we'll see
those numbers drop big time
by next week we'll show you those
numbers in just a bit 82 degrees
overnight clear and warm your winds
staying light overnight and light again
for tomorrow until we see those winds by
monday
109 tomorrow sunny and hotter remember
that heat warning begins
at 10 a.m the record is 111 so we'll
come close to that record but we think
the records will really be on saturday
sunday and monday when we'll set new
records there's that heat warning all
the way through monday
there are the records and there are the
numbers like we said saturday sunday
monday probably
new records will be set then the wind
comes in look at that huge temperature
drop from monday to tuesday
low 90s maybe in high 80s by wednesday
next week that is your most accurate
forecast
brian over to you